il aura fallu trois ans pour mener à
terme ses travaux le groupe chris leader
de l'optique en france a inauguré ses
nouveaux locaux
une opération conduite entre 2014 et
2016 avec pour objectif de moderniser sa
production et augmenter sa capacité nous
pouvions fabriquer jusqu'à présent 1
million 250 mille vers nous pourrons
maintenant on fabrique un million cinq
cent mille par an deuxième chose nous
avons modernisé la totalité la quasi
totalité de nos machines pour gagner en
productivité
comme une grande partie de ce que nous
vendons nos magasins et fabriqués dans
nos usines
il fallait que nous augmentions la
capacité de cette usine
martine pinville la secrétaire d'état
chargé du commerce de l'artisanat
étaient présentes pour l'inauguration
grâce à cet investissement la société
veut atteindre les 10 millions
d'articles vendus un moyen de faire
rayonner le territoire cette entreprise
porteuse du label origine france
garantie
ce plan d'investissement qui se chiffre
à 12 millions d'euros
c'est accompagné de l'embauchent 60
personnes supplémentaires ce qui est
important c'est d'avoir une usine en
france ça c'est un choix stratégique
nous a semblé important
de fabriquer nos verts en france de
revendiquer que nous les fabriquons en
france d'ailleurs dans les estampillé
origine france garantie puisque nos
clients ils sont sensibles avec
l'embauché cette nouvelle équipe la
capacité de production a grimpé de 20%
sur la période 2014 2016 pour 2017 le
groupe prévoit aussi d'améliorer la
technologie de sévères 100% devraient
être équipés de traitement anti rayures